[Music]
we tell if a girl likes you Travon and i
want to get to know you more than I do
now it got weird oh yeah
get after out you know burger mark hmm
do you want to go to prom with me check
it out
Cyclops as a lady if ever there were two
people who shouldn't be allowed to
procreate do you wearing makeup
no something you want to say to me a
note it's too easy you have a beautiful
day I just spent so much time trying to
get through each day I have to go potty
I kinda scolaire where are you going I
met a girl that actually likes me
someone that makes me feel like I'm not
alone in this world
you're just too normal normal
they only see what you want them to see
anyway you want to go you can go
anything you want to do you can do you
want different I want weird there you go
it's all yours
over here you've got to see this I won't
lie to you if you don't lie to me what
do you think do you realize this is one
of the hardest things I've ever done I
like that the only guys I'm competing
against our elderly degenerate and you
shouldn't be able to change out that
without telling me he raised me how
that's it
you're in love with this girls go for it
hey Jill
you
[Music]
[Music]
try and find some shoes around here
somewhere
I'm going on this thing I mean do I want
to play cleanup crew for a party of the
year nah yeah so what should we do then
[Music]
you